let me briefly describe the difference
between a quantum computer and a regular
computer at some level in a regular
computer you got ones and zeros which
you store in binary form and you
manipulate them and they do calculations
you can store them for example by in a
way that's that at least I can argue
simply let's say you have an elementary
particle that's spinning if it's
spinning and and that we say it's
spinning it's pointing up or down
depending on whether it spinning this
way or this way pointing up or down and
so I could store the information by
having lots of particles and some of
them spinning up and some of them
spinning down right ones and zeros but
in the quantum world it turns out that
particles like electrons are actually
spinning in all directions at the same
time one of the weird aspects of quantum
mechanics we may measure by doing a
measurement of an electron find it's
spinning this way but before we did the
measurement it was spinning this way and
this way and that way and that way all
at the same time sounds crazy but true
now that means if the electron spinning
in many different directions at the same
time if we don't actually measure it it
can be doing many computations at the
same time and so a quantum computer is
based on manipulating the state of
particles like electrons so that during
the calculation many different
calculations are being performed at the
same time and only making a measurement
at the end of the computation so we
exploit that fact of quantum mechanics
that particles can do many things at the
same time to do many computations at the
same time and that's what would make a
quantum computer so powerful one of the
reasons it's so difficult to make a
quantum computer and one of the reasons
I'm a little skeptical at the moment is
that the reason the quantum world seems
so strange to us is that we don't behave
quantum mechanically I don't you know
you can not me but you could run towards
the wall behind us up from now to the
end of the universe and bang your head
into it and you just get a tremendous
headache but if you're an electron
there's a probability if I throw it
towards the wall that it will disappear
and appear on the other side to
something called quantum tunneling ok
those weird quantum behaviors are
manifest on small scales we don't obey
them have
those behaviors because we're large
classical objects and and the laws of
quantum mechanics and tell us in some
sense that when you have many particles
interacting at some level those weird
quantum mechanical correlations that
produce all the strange phenomena wash
away and so in order to have a quantum
mechanical state where you can
distinctly utilize and exploit those
weird quantum properties in some sense
you have to isolate that system from all
of its environment because if it
interacts with the environment the
quantum mechanical weirdness sort of
washes away and that's the problem with
that with a quantum computer you want to
make this macroscopic object you want to
keep it behaving quantum mechanically
which means isolating it very carefully
from within itself all the interactions
and the outside world and that's the
hard part is isolating things enough to
maintain this what's called quantum
coherence and that's the challenge and
it's a huge challenge but the potential
isn't unbelievably great once you can
engineer materials on a scale where
quantum mechanical properties are
important a whole new world of phenomena
open up to you and you might be able to
set as we say if we created a quantum
computer and I'm not I must admit I'm
skeptical that we'll be able to do that
in the near term but if we could we'd be
able to do computations in a finite time
that would take longer than the age of
the universe right now we'd be able to
do strange and wonderful things and of
course if you ask me what's the next big
breakthrough I'll tell you what I always
tell people which is if I knew I'd be
doing it right now
you